let's move on and talk about the tragic
passing of foo fighters drummer taylor
hawkins nearly one week ago the band has
officially canceled all their tour dates
including sunday's grammy performance
but the show will pay tribute to taylor
that night and as matt cohen found out
the reality of taylor's passing is still
raw for taylor's former tour mate jack
black
[Music]
love taylor always the sweetest guy we
had we had great fun adventures
opening for the foo fighters all over
the world it's a friendship that goes
back over a decade to when jack's rock
duo tenacious d opened for the foo
fighters on tour in 2011. he always had
the greatest energy and it's really a
sad time yeah it was a shock
that's all i'd want to say right now
jack spent a lot of time on stage with
the foods music has shaped much of his
life remember this
school of rock is turning 20 next year
my best memories are just
that group of kids
and how funny and great they were
it's definitely the highlight of my
career i can say that honestly
jack's new netflix movie hits close to
home too he narrates the animated apollo
10 and a half a space age childhood the
coming of age story set around the 1969
moon landing starts streaming tomorrow
first let me tell you about life back
then my mom did work as an aerospace
engineer on apollo missions
there is the legend of when she went to
the hospital to give birth to me that
she had some paperwork that she was
still like working on a problem
mathematical equations i don't know
exactly what it was it's not like she
figured out how they were gonna land on
the moon while she was giving birth to
me that would have been a cooler
hollywood story
[Music]
you